tout
[Musique]
cette vidéo elle a été prise dans un
musée dans un musée qui a été
complètement détruit ravagée plié c'est
difficile à imaginer pour nous mais ces
images je les ai prises en 2016 dans le
musée de palmyre en syrie quelques jours
après le départ des pilleurs alors
aujourd'hui comment lutter contre la
destruction du patrimoine culturel
contre l'effacement de l'histoire et de
la culture
c'est la question que je me pose depuis
dix ans maintenant et à cette question a
priori on peut rien faire c'est des
problèmes qui nous dépasse je vais
essayer de vous démontrer linverse à
travers ma propre expérience donc je
suis architecte
j'ai beaucoup travaillé en afghanistan
et mon engagement m'est venue en
travaillant sur un site qui s'appelait
m'essaye lac
en fait c'est une colline donc et
fouillés par des archéologues dans sur
laquelle on a retrouvé une vie entière
une ville entière composée de
deux maisons d'atelier mais aussi de
monastère une dizaines de monastères ont
été retrouvés par les archéologues avec
à l'intérieur des centaines de
sculptures des fresques du mobilier
archéologique qui nous renseigne
énormément sur une culture qu'on connaît
assez mal la culture kushal alors le
problème principal c'est que ce que vous
voyez ici c'est en place ce monastère
par exemple tout va disparaître dans
quelques années
tout va être détruit alors pourquoi
parce que sous ce site on a un des plus
grands dépôts de cuivre au monde et le
cuivre ces précieux est une compagnie
chinoise est là pour à temps pour
pouvoir exploiter le site donc à la
place de cette montagne
un jour on aura un cratère alors les
archéologues essaye de se battre pour
sauver ce qui peuvent sauver c'est à
dire effectivement les plus petites
sculptures peuvent être transportés mais
on ne peut pas transporter les
architectures donc finalement la
solution nous a été donné par la
nouvelle technologie
j'ai proposé aux archéologues au
gouvernement afghan d'utiliser des
drones qui nous ont permis en quelques
jours de prendre des milliers d'image
sur ce site alors des images général de
la montagne des images d architecture et
d images des détails archéologiques
c'était d'autant intéressant d'utiliser
les drones que sur ce site
il reste encore beaucoup de mines anti
personnel c'est un site qui est encore
très dangereux et donc ça nous a permis
de documenter tous alors c'était à
l'époque avec des outils rudimentaires
mais ça nous a permis quand même en
quelques jours d'avoir une vision
générale
donc ces images après on les a utilisés
grâce à des algorithmes d'intelligence
artificielle pour reconstruire le site
en trois dimensions de manière
complètement photo réaliste et grâce à
cette technique
donc on travaille avec nos ordinateurs
en afghanistan il ya régulièrement des
coupures de courant ont été obligés de
recommencer à nouveau les calculs
c'était très compliqué mais à force de
persévérance on a réussi à créer une
base
cette base est composée de milliards de
points qui reprennent à la fois la forme
des montagnes la forme d architecture et
les détails archéologiques
donc c'est un outil d'archivage qui est
extraordinaire mais on s'est aperçu
aussi que c'était un outil de partage
le site est dangereux les communautés
scientifiques ne peuvent pas forcément
aller sur ce site et elles ont pu
continuer à travailler
scientifiquement à prendre des mesures
sur ces architectures sur ces sites
grâce à cette base numérique qui pouvait
être visible dans le monde entier alors
à partir de ces premiers éléments en fin
de ces premiers résultats qui étaient
qui était très intéressant pour le monde
scientifique et pour l'archéologie
j'ai décidé de créer une start up avec
un collègue huit pilotes de drones
on a décidé de développer cette
technologie
on a monté des partenariats un petit peu
partout dans le monde avec des
chercheurs pour améliorer ses
algorithmes d'intelligence artificielle
qui nous permette de recréer en fait ces
mondes numériques
à ce moment là malheureusement en syrie
en irak ont commencé les grandes
destructions de l'état islamique
moi j'avais travaillé déjà en syrie
j'avais des collègues en fait qu'ils
venaient de ces deux pays
des archéologues qui se battaient
quotidiennement pour pouvoir sauver ces
sites qui se bat qui se battaient de
manière héroïque avec très peu de moyens
là vous avez effectivement entre
parenthèses et technique de
reconstruction et cette base numérique
qui reprend à la fois
la forme de la montagne est également
toutes les architectures donc c'est des
milliards de points qui permettent de
décrire finalement un espace un
environnement avec tellement de
précisions que les archéologues peuvent
travailler dessus
donc au moment de ces destructions en
syrie en irak
j'ai contacté mes collègues mes anciens
collègues archéologue et pour moi
c'était tout naturel de leur proposer de
meilleurs complètement spontanée mais
connaissant son savoir faire
technologique un support technique pour
les aider à numériser leurs sites
archéologiques et c'est comme ça que je
me suis retrouvé embarqué dans des
aventures et notamment la première
aventure s'arrêtait en irak du nord où
on a été guidé par l'armée kurdes en
fait les pechmergas jusqu'à la frontière
de l'état islamique donc là on est sur
la frontière de l'état islamique
derrière les collines en fait c'est
effectivement les zones dans lesquelles
on ne peut pas accéder
on est venu avec cette fois ci un autre
drone on appelle un drone longue
distance et un drone qui peut parcourir
une trentaine de kilomètres de manière
complètement autonome donc ce qu'on fait
c'est qu'on lance ce drone on a cette
antenne gigantesque qui lit à côté et
qui nous montre en temps réel ou et le
drone et on attend et si le drone
revient alors le drone est toujours
revenu il revient avec des milliers
d'image et ses milliers d'image elles
nous permettent à nouveau de
reconstruire de recomposer les sites
voilà et là vous avez par exemple la
recomposition 3d d'un site qui est un
site très important de la région qui
s'appelle le site de nîmes rude au
premier plan ayant une espèce de petite
colline conique ses collines les appels
des ziggourat en fait c'est des
monuments sacrés et de de l'
architecture mésopotamienne cette image
c'est la dernière image de cette igora
tu qu'on est on ne le savait pas à
l'époque mais quelques semaines plus
tard l'état il s'agit enfin de pilleurs
qui était encore sur le site ont
complètement détruit 7 igora tu es voilà
la ziggourat telle qu'elle était quand
on l'a survolé et la voilà maintenant
aujourd'hui telle qu'elle est
complètement
détruite au bulldozer donc ça c'est pour
vous qu'on pût repreniez l'importance
fondamentale d'aller sur le terrain dès
que les zones deviennent accessibles
parce que c'est une véritable course
les sites disparaissent à une très
grande vitesse de la même manière
quelques mois plus tard j'ai reçu un
appel des archéologues syrien qui me
disait de venir en urgence à damas pour
aller sur le site de pamiers les
pilleurs du site de palmyre venait de
partir du site donc avec une équipe
d'archéologues syrien d'une dizaine
d'archéologues syrien que j'avais formé
à damas on est allé sur les lieux pour
observer déjà le désastre la destruction
de ses tantes
on a décidé de numériser un à un chacun
des temples chacune des architectures
qui restait sur le site
alors là bien sûr on arrivait trop tard
les temples était déjà détruit alors je
me suis posé la question comment
utiliser ces techniques pour
reconstruire les tempes tels qu'ils
étaient avant leur destruction
on a conçu un programme capable
d'aspirer sur internet automatiquement
toutes les images de ces temples tels
qu'ils étaient avant leur destruction
alors c'est des images ces images de
touristes par exemple peut-être vos
images si vous êtes allé sur le site
ces images d'archéologues c'est le plus
image possible et grâce à ça on a réussi
à réunir plus de quatre mille images qui
nous ont permis de reconstruire ses
temples dans leur état d'origine
voilà une première reconstruction et
voilà la reconstruction dans des temples
les plus importants uniquement à partir
des images des années 30 de vieilles
archives on avait retrouvé justement en
travaillant avec avec les archéologues
alors l'idée de reconstruire ses sites
en trois dimensions tels qu'ils étaient
avant leur destruction
ça nous a permis aussi de superposer en
fait l'état actuel du site détruit avec
l'état peut-être qu'il était avant ça ça
nous sert ça serve aux archéologues ça
serve aux architectes à comprendre
comment les destructions ont été opérés
à voir exactement ce qui reste sur le
terrain
éventuellement à pouvoir imaginer dans
le futur un remontage de ses monuments
pour aider les restaurateurs on a pu
construire comme ça des véritables bases
de données en fait qui était
effectivement
des outils d'étude qui sont des outils
d'étude pour le futur pour la
reconstruction c'est 6 alors que ce soit
en syrie en irak
chaque contexte nous demande de créer
une nouvelle méthodologie de d'inventer
des nouveaux outils des outils
techniques mais aussi des outils
stratégiques sur le terrain comme on
opère etc
mais le but est toujours le même le but
c'est de conserver cette mémoire et
j'irai même plus loin
le but c'est finalement aussi de montrer
ces pays sous la lumière de leurs
richesses culturelles
malheureusement aujourd'hui c'est payant
ne les connaît que par la guerre et la
violence alors que la syrie l'irak
l'afghanistan la libye le yémen ont une
histoire qui est extrêmement il a été
des carrefours culturels extraordinaires
donc notre notre engagement notre métier
c'est aussi de partager ses modèles au
plus grand nombre et c'est pour ça qu'on
s'engage de plus en plus dans la
création d'expositions pour que les gens
puissent ressentir la beauté ce
patrimoine par exemple ça c'est une
exposition qu'on a mené avec le louvre
[Musique]
oh
ces sites que veux tu être vos enfants
ne verront jamais en partageant vos
images vous pouvez nous aider à
reconstruire ces univers ces mondes
numériques qui seront peut-être un jour
le seul témoin qu'ont et de cette
culture extraordinaire de cette richesse
que nous en tant qu'être humain on a le
devoir de transmettre aux générations
futures
merci
[Applaudissements]